[Music]
[Music]
a tv
okay made it excellent
now all you have to do is access that
fascist computer mainframe
this will be too easy
oh my non-conforming genderless
non-binary two-spirited god what's
happening did they find you
no they have no search history abort
abort
river moon get out of there
[Music]
at least what you do online is your
business protect your business
expressvpn
yeah we have to fire him yes yes
and you know what the funny thing is we
use this expressvpn we have a few
sponsor sponsors who have the balls to
support the show we use expressvpn
speaking of big tech with the tulsi
gabbard stuff
long before we did yeah uh it happened
just
changing our vpns and actually seeing
the kind of search algorithms that were
manipulated and we're glad to have them
as a sponsor go to expressvpn.com
crowder and um what is it they get an
extra you get an extra
three months free three months and there
have been no
data breaches like other vpns out there
advertising a lot of podcasts
which is funny because it almost defeats
the purpose end
kind of like someone who was a member of
the press being a press secretary
defeats the purpose of an open and fair
[Music]
[Applause]
press
[Music]
[Music]
that's called a damn good soup there you
go we got a good show for you today
isn't that right
damn good show one of you doesn't wait
wait wait you're not even playing ball
all right i guess i'll plug the hodge
twins let me try this again
we got a damn good show for you today
isn't that right fellas we got a
damn good show okay
hodge twins you can uh follow them
conservative twins and what is it
officialhodgetwins.com
yeah that's it that's our website and
what can people do they can they can
watch they can uh support us by burning
up buying our t-shirts merchandise no
say the last beard products
by picking out a patriotic t-shirt today
yeah
use discount code circle back oh my gosh
just don't wear it too
it's impossible to support their
business it looks like it's almost like
they don't want it
gerald a is here quarter black is here
he's expected amongst no communities
we do have a big show for you today we
have ted cruz on senator ted cruz later
on and i know i told you guys we're not
going to be
lobbing softballs uh got some tough
questions for him on the impeachment
on uh some of his comments and uh
hopefully he gives us some answers we
have a lot to get to we have gina we
have mark cuban
we have the impeachment a recap of that
sorry you guys had to sit through the
first day of impeachment
that was horrible the beer helped yeah
the beer helped well then we took half a
beer yeah
and they were completely sloshed
[Laughter]
that's a white boy beer it's a green
gonna make everybody gotta bring raisins
into it would he just lean back he's
like whoa
although the bavarian purity law for
brewing methods could be uh
misconstrued as white supremacy uh but
we're gonna be talking about a lot of it
but first hey you know we uh we of
course appreciate our african american
it's black history month
breeze
[Music]
it's a trend are you good for moving
forward you got everything in order all
right so uh this is where we educate you
on some little known
you all know about rosa parks you all
know about harriet tubman who was that
very well known harriet tubman she uh
you know she uh created
she created the the amtrak but she did
but there's some info that you don't
know out there so uh give us a tidbit
there quarterback
so i got this news it's breaking you
know history we're making uh making
history kamala harris is the first black
person she is the first black
person the cradle of civilization
no lies with kamala harris ah just don't
look at her your face will melt
she's also the first indian she's also
the first um these are
these are floozy in the office who slept
her way too they know that was the right
you know people i don't i hate it
sexually independent people this has
been going on for a long time
people have been marginalizing black
women's work
and whoring yourself out to politicians
for cabinet positions that is work
it is hard work difficult it's hard
marginalizing it
right you didn't do it
walk a mile and we're going to be
talking about i'm i'm very uh listen
mass voter fraud is real can't say it
affected the election mass voter fraud
is real
we have some interns right now in vegas
doing the trip that we could not afford
to do
right now with my knee so we'll have
some more verification there
the thing is i can't make claims that i
can't personally verify and so we can
personally verify
dozens of the thousands that we've found
and i will swear to that under penalty
of perjury so we have a lot of work
going on here behind the scenes mass
[ __ ] will change my mind that's
coming up soon
uh but in the vein of course of um
racism
uh you all know aunt jemima's name and
logo has been replaced
this is a big story with pearl milling
company you guys saw this
yeah yeah unfortunately um the
replacement bottle was received as
equally tone deaf
and that's well you know okay different
times that actually is an improvement
[Laughter]
oh my gosh very very crazy i was joking
that's a joke there's a joke
it's okay that's okay they haven't had
caffeine look timmy and tommy
if you guys think that they're just this
way on air they are they go to the back
why do you go to the bathroom together
that's weird
it's a twin thing when it's a onesie
what's going on yesterday they were in
my
office doing a cameo yeah twins you sure
you guys shouldn't be an only fans they
were doing a cameo
and i hear them in my office and i hear
like man shut up no you ruined shut up
and i go in and like my microphone is on
the floor
what did you do in there those cameos
get intense they do
they seem like they seem like a piece of
cake but i don't know
no i don't have to laugh all right so
this is the story obvious that's going
on
right now um first let's check in with
cnn really quickly or is it
reform or change of course still talking
we'll talk about why all of that is
false
but the story trending this morning
listen i want to be clear about this uh
this isn't an empty gesture gina carrano
i've been following her for a very long
time
yeah not only will we have you on the
show i will hire you personally i'll
hire you as a team striking coach i
don't care
if you need a job we have one for you
here at lottery with crowder there are
70 million plus americans who have your
back and this is the problem the leftist
mob comes
and they destroy people's careers and
what they do is they're basically saying
we want you destitute we don't want you
able to provide for your family for the
rest of your life it's effectively we
want you dead we want you under a bridge
somewhere
they're doing this with gina carrano so
lucasfilm disney
uh they fired gina carano from the
disney the mandalorian as that show yeah
um over posts that they called
abor a boy born here are the posts that
they call the born we have them right
here yeah people are saying she's
transphobic people were saying
that she's auntie mask and people are
saying that she's uh suppo she's showing
holocaust material
can you read that for me there uh token
one read what she wrote she wrote listen
and i don't think that you should
compare a whole lot to the holocaust
generally speaking but this was a vow
she wasn't saying all liberals were
nazis it's the famous
first they came for the jews she was
talking about what we've talked about
the dehumanizing of voices of opposition
how is she transphobic she said i want
my pronouns today to be beep boop bop oh
thank you she's transphobic because she
just didn't want to put
pronouns she didn't want to put her
pronouns in because they were having
pressure for them how is she empty
she showed a picture of a guy wearing a
bunch of masks we did that in a
commercial that's hilarious come on
and then she basically put a post up
saying this is what happens when you can
you read the part of that post there for
me token on
uh yeah so nazi soldiers could easily
round up thousands of jews the
government first made their own
neighbors hate them simply for being
jews how is that any different from
hitting someone for their political
views
right yeah oh that seems like a test to
that comment and by the way the hating
of the jews
was married with their political views a
lot of the time they tried to marry it
with the bolsheviks and they tried
listen let's not get into all of the
nazism because some people will still
tell me that i'm crazy because i think
the national socialist party is
socialist
one of those things but that that's how
they look they lay the groundwork first
so the minute she comes out to defend
herself you're like oh that's a fascist
she's somebody who's just
absolutely abhorrent is that that
abhorrent beep boop bop [ __ ]
right like how dare she post that and
then also prove their her point
right like yeah aoc said the uh ice
camps at the border was uh concentration
camps yeah yeah
so what's the difference everybody can
use that comparison
unless you're a conservative apparently
and she actually she also tweeted out
something about the election right about
election fraud saying
oh dear god oh all we want is to make
sure and
she it was a longer tweet but just want
to make sure we have free and fair
elections let's just investigate and
make sure that's cancel worthy
so that you don't wake up questioning
and this is the theme of the day by the
way
disney mass market in china will get to
mark cuban refusing to play the national
anthem
communist china and then of course the
impeachment i mean you have eric
swalwell whose forte is banging chinese
spies
wow you know i think he may be the one
person
he didn't sleep go to a dirty asian
masseuse massage parlor and they have
his picture on the wall like a dry
cleaner
as a celebrity regular client he's
talking about foreign interference yeah
eric swalwell
you bang chinese spies that is your
legacy
anthony weiner showed his penis you have
sex with chinese women
hmm it could have been worse so so there
are several words today but china's not
much worse
china is one of the themes and they want
to cancel this woman gina carano
i've followed her for a long time she's
no one has a bad word to say about her
and this is what they do they
depersonalize people they dehumanize
people
well really she's transphobic she's not
transphobic well really she uh she uh uh
what was the other thing transphobic
anti-semitic which that could not be
less
anti-semitic and anti-mask well you know
what you know who else was anti-double
mask
fouchy after he was pro double mask and
now he's anthony yes now he's probably a
mask again we're going to find out three
masks and the cdc before they change the
nih director as well i mean all these
people
trust the science and ignore your
internet time machine
because science never changes that's
nothing it got two weeks ago this isn't
like forever ago that voucher was
against these two masks
it was one week ago yeah it was one week
ago i was being generous it was our
first show
try to be generous but there's no
science for that and now it's like turns
out
now i say there is
and i'm science guy so it's true listen
what does that say about the cdc
over 400 000 people have died from the
chronovirus if that was true
you took what almost a year to tell us
that yeah yeah oh by the way yeah
hey simple and i know people say this is
reductive if masks work so well
why haven't they yeah some people say
because you haven't worn the mask oh
shut up everyone's been wearing masks it
looks like a japanese subway for private
it works so well why don't we shut down
yeah
it is yeah it's masks then social
distancing and now they're still telling
people even if you're a vaccine you
gotta
ask what's the point to get in a vaccine
i don't like needles
second vaccine for fun you get vaccine
for fun like eric swalwell come in here
have happy ending but he have frown face
we say why are you so frown faced we
giving you happy ending
why are you not happy treasonous bastard
so with gina carano they want you to
cancel and this is something too
like this is gina carano is what an
actual beautiful
beautiful woman looks like and by the
way she could be the face
for when people talk about plus size
models not test holiday
not obesity that puts you at risk of
coping complications she's an italian
woman who was a professional fighter who
has a base of muscle
and she happens to be a little bit
bigger yeah she's thick right and then
you have two seasons
with two c's man she's fine
nothing wrong with that if you want to
have a good time go watch your way and
where she was two pounds over and they
had to cover her with towels
and so she had to strip down oh no and
you can see the guys holding the towels
like this one
[Laughter]
don't send me satan don't hit me all
right so this is what they want you to
believe a beautiful brave
woman looks like and so because of
leftist conditioning and we understand
that judy is societal conditioning it's
time to play
who's that beautiful brave woman
[Music]
all right now i know this will be
confusing but keep in mind i always say
this that um and and uh if you have
children you give them a second to leave
the penis is a veritable truth weather
stick it's true it does not very true
it's not societal condition very true
it's not an op-ed in washington post
sometimes very inconvenient it does not
lie all right
so who is the beautiful brave
woman is it a
beautiful brave woman okay okay is it b
oh you know you got to give mitch
mcconnell points for trying
somebody shoot me
[Laughter]
they took away gina's guns that's it uh
or is the beautiful wave woman
c there you go
who do you guys see what do you guys say
oh i have to go with b
beautiful brave woman who is it guys c c
of course
no you're all racist
[Music]
that's do you why do you guys hate
guineas
i'm surprised that areola lady wasn't in
the lineup i would have thought you guys
would have a common bond with sicily and
you know
the moors
[Laughter]
there's a block there's a black man
hiding behind her wood [ __ ] somewhere
down the
down the 23andme genetic line is what
i'm saying we are all
from the cradle of civilization yup mala
harris wakanda
yeah come on harris all right so now we
have before we get to the impeachment
and we will
every single thing that they've
presented the impeachment is either
verifiably false
or comes from some anonymous source or
comes from some anonymous source who was
briefed on a conversation from an
anonymous source
this is journalism this is why brian
stelter doesn't want us to have a show
yeah reliable sources because generally
speaking overweight unattractive
effeminate men
uh shouldn't have shows they're worth
makeup
they don't i got a little powder on
because the lights make me shiny but
it you know it's not stellterming
brown's got lipstick on
yeah well that's because of what he was
doing in the green room yeah he comes to
the studio with makeup so i don't think
he can use it
but it's just for the studio yeah those
lights are big enough he comes to the
studio in a buffalo bill outfit and in
the green room looks and goes
so mark cuban uh attempted to ban the
national anthem and the nba said they
weren't going to play it before and i
want to read the quote after but first
we're going to go to um a little
explanation here so there's been a few
things that have happened mark cuban
said we're not going to play the
national
yeah they didn't play the national
anthem people said that's kind of weird
what happened
hmm am i in communist china oh that's
just where you want to market the
jerseys
so um people noticed it was weird and
then the nba responded by saying no
we're going to play the national anthem
and
mark cuban you know took it on the chin
like a [ __ ] so right
then jen [ __ ] was asked about it
uh at a press conference from joe biden
and answered with
word spaghetti what does president biden
think about the dallas mavericks owner
mark cuban deciding to indefinitely stop
playing the national anthem
well i i haven't spoken with the
president about the decision by mark
cuban
on the dallas mavericks i should say the
national anthem
but i know he's incredibly proud to be
an american and has great respect for
the anthem
and all that it represents and
especially for our men and women serving
in uniform around the world
good he'd also say that of course
that part of the of pride in our country
means recognizing moments
where we as a country haven't lived up
to our highest ideals which is uh
often uh and at times what people are uh
speaking to
um uh when they take action at sporting
events uh and it means respecting the
right of people
granted to them the constitution to
peacefully protest that's why he ran for
president
in the first place um and that's what
he's focused on doing every day
we need to deport all gingers oh that
really would solve the problem
i think it's rough you can't have you
can have soulless breeding pools
yeah so joking here's uh the thing there
that made no sense
just say we support the national anthem
and they should play it just stop you're
the president of the united states this
wouldn't have been a controversial issue
for
anyone no no no this was an easy way
even jfk wouldn't like
what uh why are all those colleagues
complaining about the flag
we gave them the vote why don't they go
out there and dribble the ball
well look the nba has a policy of
playing the national anthem and
and they've done it across the league
right you're supposed to stand for it
you're not supposed to protest for it
and adam silver hasn't enforced that
rule right so that was the leeway that
he gave
and then mark cuban comes out and said
no we didn't ban the national anthem
it's a part of an ongoing conversation
and i'm like
i don't know did you have you played it
yet this year no no okay that's banning
the national anthem that's taking it
away
right what reason do you have for that
here's the reason and this is what
really he says
we loudly this is the uh from mark you
in the dallas mavericks we also loudly
hear the voices of those who feel that
the anthem does not represent them
we feel that their voices need to be
respected and heard because they have
not been
okay listen you guys said for a long
time the kneeling right they said well
listen it's not that i'm not proud to be
american i said i want america to live
up to our ideals
and i'm a proud american but i'm not
proud of some of our history now you're
saying that the national anthem
doesn't represent you this is the thing
it never had anything to do with
changing policy
it is about anti-american communists in
our midst and when i said he was like
well isn't mark you a billionaire he's a
billionaire but he wants to get into the
chinese market right now that's why he
wouldn't speak out against the
horrible human rights abuses yeah i
think it's overused or people say
you don't like america get the hill out
right there are plenty of things you
don't necessarily have to like
correct for example gingers
but if you say i don't feel that the
national anthem i don't feel our
national anthem represents me so i don't
want to hear it at the game
you should probably find a country i
think in this case it's perfectly
appropriate to suggest you find a
country that has a national anthem you
will support
and go play there good luck yes
i love this texas wasted no time by the
way the governor came out and i think
the lieutenant governor
came out and they actually are putting
forward legislation saying look if
you're getting
state funding and it's a major sporting
event you are playing the national
anthem it's going to be made into a law
potentially
right and the dallas stars tweeted out
right after that like we're playing the
national anthem before every single one
of ours
come watch us half those half the
players in nhl are russian yeah exactly
they're like
americans hit your homeland i respect my
homeland
and we don't even have lowest jeans
i have to fight better for toilet paper
and still if i hear national anthem well
i'm on toilet seat i piss all over the
floor i have to stand back
what is wrong with you they don't give a
rat's ass
you guys right black americans and you
weren't conservative so much until i
kind of brought you out of the closet i
apologize for that but you guys are
doing well
yeah but do you even wasn't working out
for you even when you were
not conservatives would you have related
to black people who said oh
national anthem i don't feel like it
represents me no never felt that way i
don't feel like most black americans
feel that way every black american i
talk with oh america's flaw you know has
its mistakes but it's the greatest
country in the world
yeah but there's a subset culture within
the black community that gets all the tv
time
yeah like hollywood yeah majority of
black people don't feel that way
no but majority black people feel
they're leery of speaking out
right for retaliation as well yeah it
really is one of those how does
how does that help black americans by
just what you do is you create a wider
divide which is of course what they did
prior to the impeachment and then they
want to blame people for reacting to
this wider divide america
is flawed but certainly not as flawed as
china
disney dallas mavericks nba are you
listening
ted liu yes right right yeah absolutely
they're flawed
unless not america unless you think
we're giving the nba too hard of a time
they pulled people out of games that
held
signs up that said free hong kong right
that was that was as bad as it got and
they actually kicked them out
right right so it's not just like
they're horroring for their money on the
the jersey sales
they're actively silencing free speech
on american soil
could you imagine if the trump
administration were treating black
americans the way the hong kong
protesters were born
they were they were rightfully they
would be passed they would absolutely be
pissed
i want to take mark cuban's argument to
the next step real quick what is he
insinuating is going to happen if
people's voices aren't heard
do you think it's going to frustrate
them and maybe think oh my gosh we our
voices aren't being heard so we have to
go to the streets
like they did during the summer and i'm
not saying writing is okay protesting
fine writing bad right just so we're on
the same page right
but that's what you're implying i don't
know is there a similar situation right
now
it starts with the national anthem guys
and you know then we're a nation
of just gina carrano's running around
bopping all over the place looking hot
what are we animals
so
[Laughter]
it's a joke i'm a married man uh um
apple i mean to be on the show we would
love that gina crane
by the way subscribe on apple or android
uh if you guys are
uh not listening to the audio version
you can take it with you wherever you go
and of course the best thing you can do
in case our notifications and
subscriptions don't work
is we stream this every morning well
morning monday through
thursday through tuesday okay so just
tune in live bookmark it tune in live
watch it so you know when you check it
that way we never lose touch with you
and of course if you want to support us
louder with crowder.com club we still
have the promo code fight like hell you
get thirty dollars off
um we have a quick uh breaking news
update for emily
what's happening uh project veritas has
been um suspended from twitter
and james alright permanently uh
i don't know if permanently but twitter
has locked down the accounts of james
o'keefe and project veritas for
reporting on facebook of vp guy rosen
in his statements that facebook freezes
comments and plays in places that
algorithms think there may be a hate
speech
oh well there may be that's not scary at
all
no that the world's third i don't know
what twitter is probably not but the
world's fourth or fifth
biggest company is carrying the water
for the world's second biggest company
don't quote me on the numbers i don't
know they jockey for position whether
it's alphabet google and amazon and
apple the point is
they're all in this at what point do you
say they're in cahoots
twitter bans a journalist for reporting
on
facebook that'd be like coke shoot you
in the street for
reporting on pepsi i'm surprised i
didn't do it soon
you know i'm surprised i will say this i
hope that james o'keefe of course he
usually does follow a single party
consent laws here's when we were kids
this is what's so scary when we were
growing up there was something called
investigative journalism
yeah and it was expected that if people
were doing something untoward or people
were committing a crime and they were
caught on camera that the public
deserved to know about it
now you deserve to know nothing right
but
by the way these are the same people and
i i'm not saying you come down on either
side of this but that say edward snowden
should be fried
right these same people are saying oh
free him and make sure assange is
pardoned and everything else
but by god we cannot have project
veritas going into an abortion clinic
and actually recording what they say
and why would why would uh why do they
support assange being free oh that's
right
that's right chicks with penises
[Music]
makes it really easy to line up teams
i'm sorry ma'am do you have a penis okay
i'll just stand over here
because i don't want to be accused of
hate speech
hey my chinese brethren right i'm not a
threat to you commies okay
let's go to the trump sham impeachment
uh
here the highlights we followed the
whole first day yeah thank god we don't
have to follow the rest of it i know
and i think that there are fewer and
fewer republicans now who are going to
vote for it because the arguments have
been paper thin but you may not know and
i want
you tell me this is the question of the
day why do you think that this
impeachment is going on i was making the
case that i think it's to
make an example of donald trump so that
anyone outside the beltway doesn't run
it's to intimidate
you it's not just to make sure he
doesn't run again it's to intimidate
all of you into not even considering
representing your constituency because
we don't want to government for the
people by the people anymore we want
people who've been in the government for
52
years yeah and have to be held up by
wires and strings
so it's entertainment you know you tell
me why you think this impeachment is
going on there's really no justification
at this point but let's go to a couple
of clips that people may not know jamie
raskin
everyone's favorite prick and she i
don't know
the point is i'm not a fan so he opened
his argument assuring uh
assuring the jurors right that his case
would be based remember this based
on cold hard facts facts cold hard facts
you will not be hearing extended
lectures for me
because our case is based on cold
hard facts
it's all about the facts
cold hard throbbing
pulsating
[Laughter]
she said jersey but i'm sorry that was
kind of funny
in the same open argument i don't know
if he he presented a clearly
selectively edited video this isn't the
worst this is just to lead in he did a
lot of
stuff that he had to fix later on
clearly selectively edited video uh to
prove that trump's speech incited
violence here it is
we're gonna walk down and i'll be there
with you we're going to walk down
[Applause]
we're going to walk down to the capitol
can't vote on fraud
and fraud breaks up marry a cut there
you catch somebody in the
very fraud rules so i hope mike has the
courage to do what he has to do
i mean it's like it was first of all it
was made of windows movie maker yeah it
was really bad cuz
and the worst we got is we will walk
down to the capitol yeah i don't even
know what they were trying to do they're
not trying to do
the so the impeachment manager so cold
hard cold
cold hard vascular facts
skinny standing at attention pulsating
facts impeachment manager david sicily
silline i hope i'm getting that right he
presented evidence of a phone call
cold hard facts between trump and uh
alabama senator tommy tuberville also
interesting enough brian stelter's
nickname in high school oh yeah
hey tumerville stop it
i'm not temperville nuisance money tommy
uh tuberville uh and they were alleging
that trump pressured tubberville to make
additional objections to electoral votes
and then they said this is what
they said that mike lee was a witness to
the phone call they presented this by
the way keep in mind
as evidence if this happens in an actual
criminal court which is a theme we're
going to continue with here
you actually have a problem the phone
rang
it was donald trump and how senator lee
explains is that
that the phone call goes something like
this hey tommy
trump asks and senator lee says this
isn't tommy and
he hands the phone to senator tuberville
center lee then confirmed that he stood
by as
senator tuberville and president trump
spoke on the phone
and on that call donald trump reportedly
asked senator tubberville
to make additional objections to the
certification process
okay so this is why they use a lot of
anonymous sources
because when they say something that can
be fact checked right away mike lee like
stopped clipping his nails over there oh
that didn't happen
that never happened he says like this
yeah he goes uh
that's [ __ ] and on twitter and this
is the problem with twitter by the way
who also bans james o'keefe as we just
saw yeah which is the majority of the
sources our twitter or washington post
op-eds go to lighterwithcredit.com we
have the whole briefing there you can
check the sources it will make your head
spin
like you just ate pea soup and there's
an exorcism being performed
it is unbelievable how paper-thin
and how illegitimate these sources are
being used so this they said
okay mike lee said that michael said i
didn't say that twitter was
fact-checking saying uh actually mike
lee did
no as a matter of fact he didn't how do
you know that he didn't uh raskin cold
hard throbbing vascular facts
had to retract this piece of evidence
that was initially submitted
the impeachment manager mr sisolini
correctly and accurately quoted a
newspaper account
which the distinguished senator uh has
taken objection to so we're
happy to withdraw it's not true but on
the grounds
i love what he's just he's trying to
avoid it like we're going to send it to
we're just gonna have to take it outside
uh because it's not true
we have to take it out for reasons
because you're full of [ __ ]
you're factually quoted as hey
constituents he's full of [ __ ]
yeah uh we have like we do i do we have
to reject it because i'm full of [ __ ]
yes i love how they tried to smooth it
over yeah accurately quoted
a newspaper report and i'm like well
that should tell you everything you need
to know about the newspaper sir
just when he said it's not true he's
like
[Laughter]
so now let's move on to everyone's
favorite banger of
chinese spies oh yeah i wish i loved
anything as much as eric swalwell loves
betraying his country by banging chinese
spies
that's a passion so he came forward to i
don't even know why this guy is in
office
i don't need to talk about impeachable
why is he even a target of chinese spies
you're getting nothing
i don't even think there needs to be an
impeachment trial for eric swallow yeah
just someone walks forward goes like uh
yeah you know what we think he shouldn't
be here because um he had sex with
chinese spies i rest my case all right
guilty bye-bye let's get herpes lip out
of here
yeah it's not herpes that's from guaysha
it's facial chinese treatment
but he has the herpes from all the sex
too yeah
it's both his picture on the wall i have
his signature
you sound like a black half asian female
well that's just because i'm racist
no he's not doing it
i don't know what i'm doing up is down
down is up when eric swalwell still
holds office
he cited and this is him presenting his
evidence he said in a tweet from a
twitter user jennifer lynn
lawrence to prove that trump's base was
rebelling and committing an insurrection
in his name
the banger of chinese spicer he's
talking it has been an honor to stand up
and fight for you in our nation see that
should be standing strong on jennifer
sixth in dc with you we are bringing the
cavalry mr president
we are bringing the cavalry
that's what he's the consistent message
that's what he's just saying at the
massage park he always come in he tell
us he's bringing the cavalry
it's just his dick every time so did
they write an unheard so here's the
thing
and then uh that was a fake doctored
checkmark what
jennifer lynn yeah she she's never been
she actually came out and she said she's
never been twitter verified
so the reason they added that was
because again all of their sources are
illegitimate
not all most of their sources are
illegitimate i don't want to speak in
absolutism like they do but there are no
repercussions for them there are for me
even though i'm a comedy host
that check mark in order to try and
provide gravitas like look it's from a
verified twitter follower
and she says i've never been verified
so that is that is doctoring evidence
and this is the problem with an
impeachment of a private citizen
right and you also have uh you don't
have justice robertson patrick leahy
we've talked about this
right he is a witness a juror and the
judge in this case
in a criminal trial which is why they
didn't want to bring criminal charges
guess what you doctor evidence
you're going to have some problems
you're going to be held accountable that
is a doctored picture confirmed by the
woman
whose account was doctored herself i i
think they should be bringing this kind
of stuff up too right i don't know if
the guys who are representing trump are
gonna bring that kind of stuff up but
going back to what he said
he's saying look literally they're gonna
bring the cavalry right that that sounds
like militaristic did they ride in on
horses
did the cavalry actually show up right
did they come in modern day cavalry
which what what is that tanks and stuff
pretending
we don't have saints no there's no yeah
that's a metaphor we're going to be
there to support you and make our voices
heard peacefully
and patriotically that's bringing the
cavalry guys
i'm sorry i had someone try to do that
to me once who will remain nameless of
the big tech companies
one of the videos i said fill your hands
you son of a [ __ ] it's a line from true
grit
yeah yeah yeah and they're like well we
took that as a threat of violence
would you think i was going to throw you
in a snake pit under the moonlight
you idiot this is the thing they try and
they try and they
there's a double standard here but the
standard that really matters is not just
what people say i don't listen i don't
care if someone else uses
uses some kind of analogy using some
kind of colloquialism i'm fine with that
my problem is when they present evidence
that is clearly doctored and facts that
they have to rescind and
they can't even say because it's untrue
it burns coming out of my mouth it
should burn coming out of your mouth
because you're a liar yeah also with
eric swalwell of course he bangs chinese
spies i'm also not a fan
of his farting habit that the president
used taxpayer dollars to ask the
ukrainians to help him cheat
an election you get out now
all my girls complain you can't go
farting in a massage room
that is crazy that's not adopted at all
you got it no it's not
you got to be talking you can feel that
she's hearing pause he did this like
yeah he raised up yeah
open the air a little bit yeah it's like
it's puff i treated it like you're doing
a crossfit workout
he was between rolls yeah
to lighten up before i go on down to
mind massage parlor
and these are the people who are
impeaching the former pres like i get it
the donald trump the problem with donald
trump is that he speaks so much he
shoots from the hip and so they have all
the stuff on him the problem
is they don't speak that often but when
they do it's hysterically
bad and untrue yeah but none of this is
evidence against him like they're
playing things that make him look mean
at the very worst he just looks
mean-spirited yeah i don't even think it
looks i know i think but what's really
severe is they're lying about
almost everything let me continue on
here to
ted oh boy by the way i have a whole bun
i have a whole bunch of gripes with ted
just look at his twitter okay just look
at his twitter it's gonna scroll down
without commenting yeah it's horrible oh
my gosh this guy is so annoying
god so breathe he said ted lou said that
trump told mike pence he would go down
forgive my language ted lou's just he's
a vulgarian he said that donald trump
told pence he'd go down in history as
a [ __ ] okay this is what ted lou
presented i think you have the overlay
right there overlay
c token allen good all right
here's the truth the quote was taken
from a washington post article that
sourced it from and i quote
two people briefed on the conversation
it wasn't the two people who had the
conversation it wasn't even two
people who were in the room when they
had the conversation
it was two people who were briefed on a
conversation
which means they probably read one of
ted liu's tweets and considered it a
briefing
i feel briefed think about this yeah he
this is he presents this and he gets
really
calm called him a [ __ ] from a
washington post which of course we know
is a liberal rag right and
a source briefed on the conversation how
is this shouldn't this wouldn't be
allowed in any court of law
right objection that's hearsay yeah it's
hearsay objection
that's hearsay and i don't like you and
it's not true
it's not true here
by the way just in case you were like
well everyone makes mistakes no i think
there are ulterior motives for ted lu
because let me present this is the same
guy who by the way accused candace owens
of encouraging uh and inciting white
nationalism and hitler
i actually don't have any problems at
all with the word nationalism i think
that it gets
the definition gets poisoned miss owens
said
quote if hitler just wanted to make
germany great and have things run well
okay fine the problem is that he wanted
he had dreams outside of germany
so when people try to legitimize adolf
hitler does that feed into white
nationalist
ideology what i responded to was that i
do not believe
that we should be characterizing hitler
as a nationalist
he was a homicidal psychopathic maniac
that killed his own people
a nationalist would not kill their own
people that is exactly what i was
referring to in the clip and he
purposely wanted to give you a cut up
similar to what they do to donald trump
to create a different narrative that was
unbelievably dishonest
ted luke could never look at a strap-on
again
and by the way after that eric swalwell
put him in a wig and uh invited him to
massage parlor
don't look at me don't look me i don't
think it was prudent for for candace
owens to
generally speaking if you bring up
hitler as a comparison or example use it
in the bad column
but yeah he was clearly misleading
people on what she's saying of course i
don't even know if he knew maybe he's
called maybe he's actually colorblind
and he has no idea who's sitting in
front of him
i'm offended i'm colorblind and i don't
want to be true i'm associated with ted
you're heavily racist the guy is pretty
damn stupid
yeah he's about here's another one by
the way we're talking about inciting
violence what about ted lue where he
said that there would be riots if trump
fired mueller if the president does go
ahead
and fire robert mueller we would have
people take to the streets i believe
there would be widespread civil unrest
we would you'd have people riot no no no
no no
i don't think that he was bringing
rioters with him yeah
i don't think he was bringing cavalry
yeah they already had it pre-planned
it was pre-planned it was pre-planned
but my point is like what about the
stand we will have rioting in the
streets put that in writing
we will have right did you not say we
will have writing in the streets i was
talking about a friend his last name we
no we just we just meant protesting
protesting's never gone bad in these
communities around the country that feel
like their voice isn't being heard
because we said their voice isn't being
heard
i was talking about [ __ ] notorious
[ __ ] triad leader
yang we she's cute
sometimes put a wig on them ship them to
eric swalwell and him oh
jeez just put him in the bottom drawer
he's never going to live that down all
right
massage party you say dick too big
too buku they're too big you get out of
here
that's what these two big go these are
words that eric swalwell has never heard
they say it to me
they say it to me they say oh you're too
big i know it's a problem
they say you get too big i say tell me
something i don't know
i don't know everything else yeah fair
point
even cnn had to call him out when cnn
calls you out it must be really bad
yeah they called him out when he
live-tweeted insults during the uh the
uh was it uh
the jeff the jeff sessions congressional
testimony right we have it right here
i am choosing words that the president
united states uses on his own twitter
i understand that but does that make it
administration okay but does that make
it right i mean do you like seeing the
president use words like that like lion
ted
so then you repeat them until their
present changes keep doing it because i
do want to highlight how ridiculous it
is
absolutely is is that a grown-up thing
to do
when they go low we stay low
i'm always low i'm five two i always low
well your mom and i are gonna ground you
is that a grown-up thing to do
i don't know i shop at gymboree yeah by
the way when you get called about not
just cnn but the cnn
b team morning crew that i have to watch
before this show
is that an adult thing to do i don't
know i haven't been an adult for years
it'd be great if the media did this to
all politicians this country in a much
better position right now they have like
a quota where they hit it like once a
month they go all right we we checked uh
we checked the
box so we're good now we're unbiased but
what kind of logic is that he did it so
i can do it have we not gotten out of
like the fifth grade mentality
like seriously but when donald trump had
a growing thing donald trump does
violence oh yeah i want to be clear
inciting violence we will riot but when
donald trump says fight like hell it's
violence by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
watching right now and you're subscribed
because subscriptions don't necessarily
mean a whole lot and we broadcast
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
just check in that's the best way to do
it
uh here's another one we have is it
stacy plaskett how do we pronounce her
name it's one of those things i've only
read
plastic so again i'm going through all
this here why you should know that all
of these things are verifiably
false okay you can check the sources at
lower crowder.com stacy plaskett i think
it's plasca
something like that it's close so our
christopher's outside plastic scan
teacher so
plaskett uh claimed this is what she was
claiming this is what they're building
as a narrative that donald trump knew
about the storming
and uh she said that that is uh
according to an article
about an ex-white house insider an
ex-white house and campaign
insider as you'll read who has known
both scovino and the president for years
said there was no way that scovino and
the trump social media operation
would not have been aware of the plan
circulating online
to storm the capital because
and i quote the trump operation closely
monitored the web's darkest corners
ranging from mainstream sites such as
twitter
facebook and reddit to fringe message
boards
like 4chan and x-chan now
to the donald.win an offshoot of a
banned
reddit community dedicated to rabidly
supporting
all things trump now if you don't know
what you're watching she goes and i
quote oh yeah official
who's she quoting the article was
entirely based on anonymous
sources by the way we just said the word
of the day
comment anonymous sources
i appreciate it that's the best thing
you could do for the youtube algorithms
below if you don't even have a question
you don't want to talk with people just
comments anonymous sources that's the
word of the day because everything here
is an anonymous sources
or non-existent source by the way this
person this anonymous source if that was
not bad enough you know what they're
what they just said
there's no they must have known right i
i have no evidence of them actually
knowing i didn't see them looking
at this and go yep they saw it they
talked about it i wasn't briefed on
anything that actually happened
but they must know they must have known
because of an anonymous
article in washington post which i quote
how can you even print something like
that how can you much less go back and
refer to it and go well yeah that sounds
about right how could you even print the
first one these are the people who want
to silence all of our shows keep in mind
washington post unbelievable
by jeff bezos cnn brian seltzer they're
saying you need to get rid of the spread
of misinformation and fake news really
this is fake is this fake news you
presented these at the impeachment
fake twitter verifications documents
from people who were briefed on
conversations when they weren't even
there
and other documents uh sourced from
anonymous sources and you can't even
pronounce it correctly
x-chan x-can oh god
i'll give al sharpton a run for his
money um i was going by roman numerals
you're still wrong
by three
then she went on to but to be fair to
your point i need to include all of her
contacts because she went on to
cite a donald.win post with 12 comments
as an example oh man wow of the
underground
uh scheme movement uh is there is there
a clip i i think clip i right yeah
clip-i
this is an example of a post that was
captured from one of the sites dedicated
to donald trump
just talked about shortly before the
site was taken down
okay we'll have more than 12 comments
this very second that this is archived
and we said the word of the day
just for context and you can't comment
live because it's a liability but once
it's archived you can comment
here's the truth the first and only time
that image ever appeared in the internet
january 6th oh january so so i think
they think that donald trump is
clairvoyant like kamala harris you know
where she can travel back in time
tupac before he was a thing first black
person first black person they're
holding him to that standard
because he clearly would have known it
was planned ahead of time
how by this post that wasn't posted
ahead of time with 12 comments
look it's donald dot that's the message
board it has his it has his name
in it i rushed my case
that's a crime there are more people in
the westboro baptist church than looked
at that
they have flippers for ears right now
that's true yeah
amazing here's another one this is
evidence yeah and this is something that
i missed uh hats off to lily
and sarah who helped us research this uh
they also used a video this was
presented and you wouldn't know and i
didn't know
what i don't because of black people
with the nicknames they always have
nicknames so i didn't know that john
sullivan was the same person as jaden x
and so this is one of the videos they
presented
from jaden x you can clearly see on cnn
this is what they presented as evidence
you can see his watermark
in the video
[Applause]
see jaden x right there
[Music]
all right there you go okay i just
wanted to see jayden x right there okay
so that's jaden x that's john sullivan
yeah
after this is probably gonna change it
to martin luther jaden x
i mean i don't know i don't know like i
was the nickname it made it hard i
didn't know i didn't connect with john
sullivan thing and jaden x are you aware
this guy
no i never heard of him well but the
whole x thing is you're about to yeah
you're about to
john sullivan doesn't sound great you
guys need to get in touch with your
roots yeah
it doesn't sound very i don't want to
get in touch with them roots also also
i'm sorry about the series roots i love
that [ __ ] that was a fake
it's pretty tough for me to watch we get
it i enjoyed it joe
really yeah wow you really are
self-loathing
so this is cool jaden x jaden x is john
sullivan
this is the source they use so not
better than anonymous
better than non-existent better than
banger of chinese spies
but i would still say there might be
some
bias there because this is what john
solomon slash jaden x is all about
what's going on everybody my name is
john sullivan i'm from salt lake city
utah
my group is insurgents usa we gotta rip
trump out of that office right over
there
pull him out that [ __ ] nah nah we ain't
about
to wait until the next election we about
to go get that mother
now i don't think that that's a
misinterpretation of someone saying uh
we're bringing the cavalry
no no that seems pretty that sounds
almost literal
that sounds like a threat but
congratulations on being the only black
man in salt lake city utah so that's
good for you
fighting a good fight what does it stand
out but they're not even concerned this
guy is actually
incited this guy is actually not just i
don't know if he said it because he may
not have been successful
but called people to violence yeah
absolutely he's so bad that
even black lives matter disowned him and
you know you've got to be really shitty
that's right that is oh that hurts
though after hearing him speak i
understand why he went with jaden x it
sounds much tougher sounds much tougher
by the way when you're doing a speech
like that you're threatening violence
don't wear a rash guard that shows you
look like a famine victim
there's nowhere to surf you're in utah
okay uh
here's by the way here's part of his
capital footage that they also
they didn't present they didn't show you
i never would have imagined that we
would be here
dude i was trying to tell you i i
couldn't say much
you were right you just have to watch my
chat
is this not going to be the best film
you've ever made in your life
[Applause]
hell yeah oh yeah hell yeah you weren't
recording right
i'll delete that but i didn't record
your man
this sorry to make you aware sweetheart
he in fact did not delete that [ __ ]
no that is a lie uh to be fair mr x
doesn't know where the delete button
is now look
i'm not saying that that proves that
there was antiphon like this with stage
but here's the thing look a guy going in
there who said pull that
pull that man out of office which let's
be clear if he's willing to actually
commit a felony
a violent act a treasonous violent act
against president united states
why would he be uncomfortable lying
about him of course they're going to
bring him forward to lie just like the
women who lied about brett kavanaugh and
then they rescind it but no one covers
that story anymore so right now they
present jaden x and then when it comes
out he's a lion piece of crap and he's
actually committed acts of violence
they'll rescind it and they just won't
have any accountability at that point
but think about this for a second that
guy is there um
what if he shoves somebody yeah right
that's it doesn't need to be a whole
group of influence he shoves somebody
and someone reacts we've seen this
happen yeah it changed my mind it takes
one person and that's why you have to
have security
this is the point it was a powder keg it
wasn't just one
group of people and you're not being
honest about it because i think you know
that if people saw that video and they
understood the video that you were
showing was of a guy
goading them on and a guy who had
previously called for violence
why would the guy who said hey pull the
[ __ ] out let's burn this down
what would stop him from committing
violence on that day when he's talking
about how great it is
or inciting it more than donald trump
did right if you think donald trump
incited it we don't think he did but
do you don't think he was egging them on
as they were heading that way so that he
could get
man the best footage i've ever gotten in
my life right and be incredibly excited
in that moment he didn't like that
footage he got up and
in well look no well that's what dogs do
we don't call him out for that
that's his culture gosh all right
different strokes right all right it's
better than what he wants more
[Laughter]
down and everything now you distracted
me
right it was probably good my blood
blood pressure was going up well look
two things can can be true in this case
right micro said
made a really good point about it no no
no going back to this
everything that we see right now by the
way is democrats showing you how bad it
was that day and i will
granted there were heroes that day who
made sure that people got to safety
there were people that did a fantastic
job of being patriots of course
and doing their jobs right it was
horrible that people broke in and did
what they did it's horrible that
people's lives
were cost in this right that is true but
they're trying to make a connection to
donald trump that is not true
they're saying this is true and
therefore trump is wrong for doing well
this brings me to what i think to what i
think is the most important point here
that uh hopefully you guys if you're out
there
we can clip this get it up because this
is a timeline that i haven't heard
anyone else talk about
and i know people will be upset because
anytime you discuss the deaths at hand
you discuss the truth people get mad and
they say why
why are you why are you downplaying the
death that's not what i'm doing and by
the way of course
we do support people in law enforcement
who are doing their job well and i do
think that there are tragedies and i do
think that people who committed
unwarranted violence of course deserve
to be prosecuted have i set
have i set the context enough okay
because it also matters
if the house impeachment managers and it
confused me and i follow this for a
living
uh presented a video that claimed at
least seven and i was like what happened
to five
yeah seven's a new five they claim that
seven people died that's not true here
you go
okay that is uh a lie yeah
now let me be a crazy guy really clear
about this okay ashley babbitt is a
person who we know was was shot by the
police yeah
obviously and that's horrible that's a
tragedy i'm really really that genuinely
makes me sad that that happened yeah
okay absolutely
there were five reported deaths there
were not seven reported deaths initially
now they changed it uh the seven
includes two officer suicides which
happened days after the riots
no cause by the way is known someone who
was trampled uh to death in a
what was reported as a medical emergency
we don't have all the information on
that yeah
two of the other five died of a heart
attack and a stroke
and the times of death cannot be
confirmed now the one that they focus on
as far as the officers officer officer
sicknick um he was originally reported
to be bludgeoned to death with fire
extinguishers and as
everyone here i'm sorry we're all
horrified to hear that and if that did
happen we are in fact
horrified to hear it if someone
bludgeoned them to death with a fire
extinguisher i want to see them fly
okay that being said there was
misreporting here which is cited as a
source with the impeachment folks the
reports of his death went to twitter at
5 54
p.m it was a misreport his time of death
was listed at 9
30 p.m 9 30 p.m cycnic's autopsy uh it
hadn't been released
reports uh refuted that he died from
blunt force trauma by the way it's not
been released yet there are reports that
are refuting that
already here's the thing with sicknick
too because this matters i'm about to
get to the trump video on the timeline
where they try to say that he condoned
violence
he texted his brother after returning
from the riots saying that he was okay
but he got pepper sprayed twice
his family later learned he suffered a
stroke and that he died on the seventh
right the report of his death was at
nine something p.m i think 9 54 pm yeah
and by the way
investigators have been completely
unable to match the video of him being
attacked with the fire extinguisher
uh they don't have that video of him
being blessed in death with fox and
there's a ton of footage
doesn't mean it didn't happen right yeah
but again you sp but you said seven
deaths
and two are suicides days later and
other ones are unconfirmed in a heart
attack and a stroke
listen you are standing on the graves of
people and politicizing it yeah this is
already tragic enough
this is already wrong enough it's
nowhere near the black lives matter
riots
as far as damage as far as deaths as far
as they're casual this is not even close
and you guys encouraged that we'll have
a super count of that on monday i bet
you they're probably bringing up in the
impeachment
all of trump's worst versus all of the
worst folks saying summer of love
and we're gonna burn this down and these
people need to be heard and riots are
the voices of the unheard
you are the party of encouraging
violence and telling businesses in
california you know what we're not gonna
just don't report the theft unless it's
a thousand dollar minimum that's what
was happening in california
okay so you said seven after we had
heard five and here's something else
that is really
important to note it was at 2 38 p.m
after the rise trump tweeted this
exactly please support our capitol
police and law enforcement they are
truly on the side of our country
stay peaceful now what they're trying to
say is donald trump said we love you
to them like he said i love you to
writers you're killing people keep in
mind that every single one i mentioned
most of them were days later none of the
deaths at this point
had been reported none no deaths had
been reported just injuries at this
point where donald trump released this
video
where he said you need to be peaceful
and he said we love you because he was
at this point talking to people who
rioted something got out of hand but at
this point there were no deaths yet it
wasn't like black lives matter
here's the video so go home we love you
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace
we have to have law and order we have to
respect our great
people in law and order we don't want
anybody hurt
that was before any deaths were
confirmed after deaths have been
confirmed
after many many many deaths after 100 of
officer casualties confirmed after
billions of dollars in damages
you still have leaders of democrat
cities who haven't said that
who haven't said you need to go home and
stop can you imagine this for a second
do you think for a second if it again at
this moment
in time context no one had died yet
there were only injuries nowhere near
the severity of black lives matter not
at all not saying that
not saying that the attack here is
justified but let's imagine a scenario
okay where black lives matter breaches i
don't know let's say breaches the cnn
building let's say breaches some state
capitol building
and there's at that point there's no
deaths right they're saying we need to
be heard
could you imagine could you imagine any
democrat politicians saying anything
other than their voices need to be heard
and we need to not be violent but still
we need to listen to them
they wouldn't have spoken as strongly
and condemned black lives matter as
strongly as donald trump did
before there was a single life lost how
do i know because you've had months
and you haven't done it
and a number of people even just thought
they were peaceful protests in the first
place and defended the writing even
though they could see the cars burning
right behind the cnn reporters saying
that it was mostly peaceful protest
one quick question and i don't want to
step in anything here but where are all
the people
like that were saying that police
brutality and police shooting people in
situations maybe where they didn't need
to
with with ashley and a lot of people
have brought this up like did it was
that a justified shooting
and that's a question i don't i don't
know i haven't seen everything about it
haven't seen every angle
right yeah when she was shot i think it
was through glass and protesters was
obvious
obviously at that point turning into
rioters and trying to come through so i
can understand fearing for your life but
if the guy in the wendy's parking lot
that fought two police officers
tossed them like ragdolls grabbed the
taser ran off and started to shoot a cop
can't be shot
can ashley right is it just because she
was on the wrong team that day
exactly that's why you don't bring
anything up about this right just
curious
yeah no it really is a remarkable double
standard and it's not even close
if you're to weigh the scales of the
violence and the carnage and the
condemnation the response from democrats
it's never been as strong listen it has
been over the course of the entire
summer of love as a seattle um yeah i
believe referred to it yeah it's been
going on all summer and into the fall
for crying out loud they had to change
their merch to seasonal wear
and what happened with donald trump one
one where there were some poor
some supporters for donald trump one and
at this point there were no deaths and
he immediately said we support law
enforcement you need to go home we need
to be peaceful
he can't say we love you but you got to
go home do you understand what a hostage
negotiation is at that point at this
point there are no lives lost
let's not make it any worse we love you
guys we understand why you're upset but
you need to go home
as opposed to the left who says we love
you guys we understand and i think that
there's a gymboree down the block that
you can burn down
uh walgreens is very flammable yeah well
and there's a rand paul leaving the
event so go
go mob him right yeah go mob him and
we'll
uh get money together and bail you out
of jail exactly so you can do it again
right right yeah people who repeat it
who committed murders people who
committed theft people committed rapes
who were being bailed out thanks kamala
or vp helping with that bail fund all
right we do have to get going we're
going to talk uh
with ted i believe we have him i'm going
to talk with ted cruz in a little bit
everyone there remember what are the
days anonymous sources comment your
thoughts on impeachment
seeing this has it changed your mind at
all comment comment comment comment and
after ted cruz we're going to go uh to
mug club and take your chat
all right let's get going to this editor
[Music]
trump has left office he's no longer
president
at this point they're simply exercising
their primal rage they hate the man
so much and you know you think of the
challenges facing this country
i mean we've got a global pandemic we
have tens of millions of people out of
work
i think they need to put their partisan
hatred aside
and and and focus on actually working
for the american people
getting america back to work helping
small businesses
this is going to be just venting
the id of the democrats and then it's
going to end
with failure in order for the president
to be convicted it takes 67 votes
in the u.s senate that's not going to
happen rather than focus on getting kids
back in school
and getting tens of millions of
americans back to work
the democrats want a week of of just
political theater raging at donald trump
and there you have it of course that is
a clip of our next guest political
theater
that's the word he used um which
is almost an insult to theater somewhere
ethel merman is rolling over in her
grave singing clan clan clang with the
trolley uh
our next guest you can follow him on
twitter for as long as they allow him at
ted cruz or at send
ted cruz uh his podcast is verdict with
ted cruz and his
his book is one vote away which he
hasn't sent us a hard copy yet senator
ted cruz how are you sir
i am doing great and and since you're
you're lacking a hard copy of the book i
i'm happy to demo it
and and we will send you this copy right
here it is
in the mail along with a check oh your
book is in the mail so i can expect that
to be lost
do fedex please let's go the private
route uh
just to be sure okay so senator cruz we
have a lot to get to
and some some tough questions because i
promised my audience that we'd be asking
republicans some tough questions here
uh and you've got some explaining to do
but not a lot um
first let's go ricky ricardo in a long
time
i know yeah he by the way threatened to
beat his wife mercilessly when you watch
those old shows you're like the good old
times
do you have any idea did you watch the
honeymooners boom zoom to the moon is
i'm going to
strike you so hard you will be in orbit
yeah but nobody on earth thought that
that desi arnaz could take lucille ball
she would kick his tail
and everyone knew that and so that sort
of kept it on on a nice even keel
yeah yeah and it was foreshadowing to uh
now the executive action from uh joe
biden where
trans males can beat up trans females so
who knows now
the lines are blurred the point is it's
up in the end hands up chin down
okay political theater tell people uh
what we're watching here
what do you think about this impeachment
trial i mean i i really do think it's a
shame i think that donald trump's
defense attorney the first guy um should
just should walk off a cliff
figuratively why is this happening right
now and the constitutionality is
is your strong suit but you have both
sides they always have these arguments
well the constitution and says this and
give us the the run now so let me take
both pieces number one why is it
happening because democrats hate the
president
they hate donald trump for four years
that's been the democratic party it's
been defined by this
pathological i mean there's a reason
trump derangement syndrome is a thing
that's who they are and so
this week the trial is going to be lots
of screaming lots of pounding on the
table
lots of emotional you know grasping
their ties and like
looking looking with big puppy eyes and
there's gonna be lots of videos really
heart-wrenching videos uh
but at the end of the day it's doomed to
failure they know that
every senator in the chamber all 100
senators know the outcome of this
is going to be the trump's going to be
acquitted they need 67 votes to convict
that ain't going to happen there's going
to be somewhere around 55 votes to
convict plus or minus one or two
and then it'll be over and and they're
going through this not because they
actually want to accomplish what they
say they're trying to do
but because they just hate the guy and
and and
there's no reasonable argument i believe
that this
meets the standard for impeachment the
standard is high crimes are misdemeanors
their argument is
that that trump incited the violence
listen i was here at the capitol it was
on the senate floor when when
the attack occurred it was a terrorist
attack it was
reprehensible one police officer was
murdered every one of those violent
criminals
should be fully prosecuted but if you
look at what trump said and listen i
have been
among the first to to say that trump's
rhetoric was was overheated that it went
too far i wish he hadn't gone as far as
he did but the democrats argument is
using language like
fight and win and take back our country
that that is somehow
incitement to violence and you know if
that is true you better
be prepared to line up and indict every
single political candidate for office
who's ever given a stump speech
the local candidate for dog catcher is
right now
saying we need to fight and win and take
back our country from the dogs like
this is absurd hypocrisy
they know it but but their anger
and rage towards trump is what's driving
it
now that being said that's i know you're
making light of it but it's no laughing
matter when
uh large swaths of detroit are
controlled by packs of roaming wild dogs
it's a serious elected position
and i don't appreciate your tone there
you know i'll just point out that
the great state of texas where you and i
both reside the legislature
changed the law to legalize hog hunting
from helicopters
yes yes which may be the glove texas
like like now look hogs are a pestilence
and they destroy crops and
they do all sorts of damage but but it
is still
thoroughly bad ass and i'm going to
admit to you right now stephen
that that i i
feel completely
incomplete as a person until i actually
get up at a helicopter and hunt hogs i
haven't done it yet
trying to make that happen very very
soon
and and i'll let you know what i do and
so you know the wolves that have taken
over
that those can be dealt with too yeah
they can well they're not wolves they're
just actually wild dogs
that's a perfect example actually in
detroit you know michigan um
where i spent quite a bit of my time
they had a vote for a wolf hunt in the
upper peninsula of michigan i don't know
how familiar you are but that's
separate by a large body of water so
yes the u.p serious people we have
someone from wisconsin who works here
even brendan and he thinks it should be
part of wisconsin
but he's a [ __ ] so um they had a vote
on a wolf
hunt because there was a problem in the
u.p and it was voted down
you know why because a bunch of hipsters
and detroit coffee shops thought it was
mean they're like well the wolves keep
the popular the coyote population in
check the ups
they said the you person we're more
concerned about the wolves than the
coyotes right now
and that's a problem i think with a lot
of politics we have americans who feel
their voice doesn't get heard because
some people in big cities
just uh you know they overrule their
vote why are people in detroit voting on
a wolf hunt for people in the u.p
and that brings us back to the election
now you just said and this is something
that i know you've caught some heat for
donald trump went too far in his
rhetoric
could you give me some examples what do
you what do you mean by that
oh look i i by the way that this is not
a new sentiment i
i think trump's rhetoric often goes too
far i wish what he said and what he
tweets
was just ratcheted down a toner to
actually think he he would have been
more effective without all the drama
that there were some unforced errors
and so listen with regard to the last
election i think the president's saying
over and over again that the election
was stolen it's overwhelming
and completely clear i actually don't
think the evidence backs that up i think
there
is serious evidence of voter fraud that
needs to be investigated it's why i
stood up on the floor of the senate
and brought together 11 senators calling
for
an election commission to review the
evidence but i think
determinations like that ought to be
actually based on evidence and facts
and not just stating the outcome you
want which is it was stolen because i
say so
i i think it's much better to have it
actually
derived from and connected to the facts
but here's the thing
you know that most of these cases were
dismissed that the evidence wasn't even
heard i mean
the supreme court in particular right
dismissing it on standing
so what does president trump do what and
not just president trump but the 70
million
americans who voted for him were saying
well hold on there's no due process here
we've shown irregularities and we might
be banned from social media if we show
these irregularities
um how do we say it's not based on
evidence when evid i know the standard
we're talking about evidence proven in
court
but they haven't heard the evidence let
me ask you this have you seen
ev do you believe that you've seen
enough evidence to say there have been
some serious irregularities
and large levels of fraud in the last
election i i think there unquestionably
have been serious irregularities and
what we know that the
democrats have done in state by state
what they certainly did was change the
rules to benefit them so the move for
example the universal mail-in balloting
let's take a state
a state of pennsylvania right where they
move to universal mail in balloting it's
contrary to the pennsylvania state
constitution
they ignored the law and they did it
because they understand
that for a long time mail-in balloting
has been the greatest source of voter
fraud that it is susceptible
uh to ballot harvesting it's susceptible
to to things like uh you take a nursing
home
uh when you have universal mail-in
balloting political operatives can go
into a nursing home to a bunch of
folks who may not be competent anymore
to make determinations
and fill out the ballots for them and
mail them in and by the way
if if one of the nursing home residents
is stubborn and votes the wrong way from
the political operative's view then just
throw their ballot out and that's a
problem
you know just a couple of months ago in
texas a woman was indicted for voter
fraud for doing exactly that over 100
ballots she went to nursing home
residents
to fill out many of them were not
competent were not capable to understand
what they were doing and she was trying
to steal votes and so mail-in balloting
is particularly susceptible
and it's not just me that says that by
the way there was a bipartisan
commission a number of years back
it was chaired by jimmy carter and james
baker it's called the carter baker
commission
jimmy carter is hardly some right-wing
kook well you also have the letter
written from elizabeth warren and amy
klobuchar two i believe it was the
parent company of dominion
not saying that it was a ghost of hugo
chavez who came back stole the election
but saying hey
these machines are not secure in what we
in the standards that we require for
national elections signed elizabeth
warren
amy klobuchar so it was okay to say that
and posted on social media
until recently now it's considered
treason i guess or a high crime
so listen what i would say is there
there is significant evidence
that there was meaningful voter fraud
that that is deeply concerning
and you were right that many of the
court cases were decided on procedural
grounds they didn't get to the merits
they didn't get to the underlying
evidence because of procedural barriers
it's
why on january 6 i stood up and led the
objection and raised the objection
because i said listen there's enough
evidence prima facie evidence on the
front
to raise a serious concern we need to
appoint
an impartial election commission that
can consider the evidence
on the merits and make a conclusive
determination
i still think that would have been the
right path to take if we had done that
and reviewed it on the merits
you know you've got nearly half the
country
that that believes the election was
rigged that's not good for the stability
for confidence in our democracy
i think having a process to conduct a
fair audit would have been much better
right unfortunately the senate didn't
agree well i would argue worse for
democracy and the trust of our
constituency is is
potentially elections being rigged you
know insecure
according to democrats before this
election and i think that a lot of
people feel as though their vote doesn't
matter going forward
you know and that asks me because they
go well listen if this is what happened
in the last election there's over 30
plus million americans who feel that way
uh specifically on election fraud what
do you think the future of the
republican party is because i think you
have a lot of people who are mad saying
you do need to fight like hell and
people are willing to move on and take
this on the chin
and i tell you what for me because you
know we we cross reference we have an
intern with pictures of today's
newspaper in nevada addresses that don't
exist
we could only go to so many dozens of
addresses to show these are not valid
addresses
this is a fake vote we can prove it i
would say it under court
or threat a penalty of perjury because
we i've seen this myself
i can't say that i've seen everything
else this is what i can claim in court
and no court would admit it as evidence
what's the future of the republican
party do we think there's a place for
the liz
cheney's of the world and the trump
voters of the world
so listen i think there should be a
place for everyone who's willing to vote
to save our country and
and i do think efforts actually on
either side within within the republican
party to purge either purge
trump supporters or purge those who are
skeptical of the president i think both
of those are mistakes
i want to win i want to get to 50 plus
one i i want to actually have
policies that make sense for our country
that defend our liberties that protect
our free speech and our religious
liberty and our second amendment i want
those policies in place
and so i think we should be growing the
team of supporters now
does that mean we give up and stop
fighting absolutely not to the contrary
we need to stand up and fight for what i
believe in and what you believe in and
what all of us believe in we need to
fight
seriously and and effectively
and figuratively and and figuratively
you actually have to clarify that
because when you say fight i'm not sure
you treasonous bastard
you know and this is a battle
an electoral battle that will go on
defending liberty is not
is not easy election fraud is a serious
threat i've spent 20 years fighting
voter fraud when i was
solicitor general of texas i led the
states defending photo id laws in the
states
right voter fraud is a real problem and
and we need to fight against it
that being said i do think you sometimes
see republican politicians
who say who use voter fraud as an excuse
i can tell you my approach what i've
been on the ballot is yes voter fraud's
a problem we need to fight it and combat
it
but for the election coming up right now
here's the simplest answer
win by a big enough margin that they
can't steal it from
right and and i do think from the
approach of get the job done
that is important and i'll give you an
example where we didn't get the job done
which is the georgia senate runoffs on
january 5th
right now i went down to georgia three
separate times and campaigned on the
ground those were the most important
senate races of our lifetimes
we lost them both that is what handed
the senate over to chuck schumer
the country is going to go through some
horrible policies
because we lost those races what
happened in georgia
all the democrats showed up they were
angry they were united
they they were invigorated to
to jam through the socialist policies
that they're getting ready to push
through
and our guys stayed home our guys were
depressed they were demoralized
uh and and they didn't show up and and
well it's because they felt a lot of
them felt like their vote didn't matter
you know like you just said win by a
large enough margin you have a lot of
people in this country who
think that did happen and they could
still they could still steal it that's
we haven't seen the evidence but i'm
just saying i understand how those
people feel i still think they should go
out and vote but it does in some ways
for many americans right now feel like a
hopeless endeavor
and they just don't feel like
republicans are fighting for them enough
look are republicans fighting enough no
and then that has been a a persistent
problem
but we can win we have one you look at
even this election where
where we won most of the close senate
seats
and we gained a bunch of seats in the
house of representatives
but it is about turnout you know it
reminds me of you know john madden that
when he was uh you know you play those
video games or watch him announcing
football you know saying things like
well well you know if if you score more
points than the other team
you're going to win the game that
you said
you know that that's true in politics
too which is if their voters show up and
your stay home
you're going to lose the election but
it's not true if it's like a boxing
match and the guy keeps punching you in
the nuts and the ref doesn't call it and
then you keep trying to keep it above
the belt i think that's what a lot of
people feel it right now
even outside of voter fraud even that
democrats play dirty
i mean for a crying out loud senator ted
cruz aoc said you tried to have her
murdered for chris i mean that is the
most absurd thing i've ever heard
by the way your response and i know
you're going to be nice about it but
let's have something
that needs to be commensurate with the
accusation she said that you tried to
have her murdered
i can't think of something that could
inspire one to violence
more than a statement like that because
if i believed you were actually a
murderer you know timothy olafan
shaved head hit man i'd probably i'd
probably get physical with you if i
believed it
look she she's unhinged
but i don't need to respond in kind i
don't need to
scream you know ah you're a terrorist
run away
like like it's just the left has lost
their minds and and i actually think
it's much more effective
to respond with with a smile to respond
with humor
i i don't take a screaming socialist
who who believes that that like people
are trying to have her murdered i don't
take that seriously i think it's
nutty and and it's it's self-parody
you don't actually have to i don't think
you need to say much other than well
that's pretty crazy
your two reasons here's the problem
you're intelligent you're too reasonable
and there are a lot of people in the
country who aren't but more importantly
the media doesn't care after the aoc you
know it came out that she wasn't there
when she wasn't when she was in the uh
cannon building she was she was several
miles away right we covered this in
depth
and the pipe bombs weren't planted
anywhere near her and she kept changing
her story
after all this occurred two days later i
was listening to i have an abc news
update my
and my uh kind of set to my podcast
stuff just because i want to hear what
they're saying
on friday they said aoc described her
harrowing experience at the state
capitol
and i thought oh they're going to
address the controversy now as though it
didn't even happen
so i know that you think it's and i
think she's crazy we know she's
certifiable
but the media doesn't treat it that way
and then it's a drip drip drip with
enough americans who absorb it and they
think oh well ted cruz is an attempted
murderer
yeah look there's no doubt about it and
the media is
utterly complicit one of the
consequences of the last four years is
the media's broken
that there is not anything you look at
something like cnn which is
i tell you four years ago you could see
them trying to be journalists
they don't try now they hate trump so
much that
they are raving partisans nobody argues
the media isn't biased anymore
nobody in the media argues that i mean
they are
passionate vicious partisans and so the
aoc thing of course and by the way aoc
the fact that she's unhinged doesn't
mean she isn't dangerous right
her idea she's an unmitigated socialist
her ideas look
this is a woman who celebrated driving
amazon out of new york and killing 25
000 jobs yeah with a six-figure average
pay
you know who who needs who needs jobs i
mean these people
are the ideas they're putting forward
would do enormous damage to our country
and by the way
they're vicious part of the reason she's
claiming that i tried to have her murder
is is this is like robosphere the hard
left
they want to destroy all their enemies i
mean
they are trying they're trying to
destroy donald trump why is this
impeachment hearing happening
because they hate him so much that they
figure let's drive a stake through him
and it's driven by hatred and extremism
and they want to drive a stake through
you and me and and they're trying to
erase
all 75 million americans who voted for
trump
and right now the media is fully in on
it big tech is fully in on it
i mean it is this is the empire strikes
back to
to shift to a different movie reference
i mean they are right now
we will crush the rebellion was that
darth vader or was that the
palpatine i don't know star wars um that
was darth vader although i probably need
to work on my impressions
you may be safe i just
i just don't follow nerd lore but i
understand the reference
but here's the thing senator cruz and
we'll we're getting i know anybody by
the way i don't entirely believe you i
think you probably have like the
watchman graphic novel hidden underneath
your desk and you're just
uh you're a recovering nerd pretending
to be cool no i've talked about this on
the show i watched
i i viewed the watchmen on a flight and
i walked out
that's how much i dislike the watchman
um
i said is that can you get that can you
get that small child the toddler to
start kicking the tv tray in the back of
my chair so it just
ruins my train of thought here distracts
me but here's the thing now they control
three branches of government to the left
republicans and i remember when you were
here you know a few months ago i said
four years the biggest issue of our time
is big tech 230.
a lot of people don't republicans or
they didn't do anything what hope do
they have now now
it's open season it's going to start
with trump and work its way down to all
of us
look it is open season it is profoundly
dangerous
all right in congress all the democrats
are opposed to doing anything about big
tech they want them to use their
monopoly power
to silence and destroy their enemies so
you've got half the congress
that is fully in bed with big tech you
then have half the republicans that are
just scared of doing much of anything
so it's only a handful of us i mean i've
been leading the fight on big tech for
the last several years i've chaired
hearing after hearing after hearing i've
been pressing for action
here's the real problem when you've got
all the democrats and half the
republicans on the other side you don't
have the votes to move something through
congress
so i proposed all sorts of things they
ain't gonna move because the votes
aren't there so the only hope
was the executive branch right for four
years we had the executive branch and
and one of the challenges
look trump understood that big tech was
a problem he wanted to do something
about it
the rest of his administration couldn't
actually effectively
execute to do something about it i can
tell you in the last four years
on this topic i have sat down and met
repeatedly
with president trump vice president
pence the white house chief of staff the
attorney general the deputy attorney
general
the assistant attorney general for the
antitrust division the chairman of the
federal trade commission the general
counsel
of the federal trade commission every
one of them laying out here are the
steps we need to take
and they did bring a lawsuit against
google that was good
right but that was focused mostly on on
commercial and anti-competitive conduct
outside of the speech and censorship
side and i could never
get the people in the administration
executing the policy
to get serious about stopping censorship
trump wanted to
and he'd say gosh i wish this would
happen but nobody in his
administration was able to be focused
and effective and competent and get it
done
that's the only way we're going to get
it done is with an executive that is
ready to act and knows how to because
you're saying there are too many
republicans
in the senate who wouldn't take part
yeah well there are the votes
how about this how about you and your
guys co-draft go write up some
legislation
and put it on the table and let's find
out who those 50 republicans are and
vote them out
so we know who they are so for example
the senate judiciary committee we voted
uh voted on the bill i don't know a
month month or two ago
um to rein in section 230 provide some
scrutiny to big tech
every single democrat voted no and half
the republicans voted no all right i
want a list of those names and i want
those people voted out because that's
the biggest issue of her time
that's i don't consider it winning if
those people i want a big tent i don't
want those namby pambies i think that's
fair
look it is an existential threat
that being said and by the way the biden
administration will do nothing because
they're bought and paid for by big tech
those are their supporters
and they want big tech to be worse it's
not even they won't reign in big tech
the biden administration is cheering for
tech to be worse
right so the only answer
frankly is when the white house and have
an executive who understands
the danger and is capable and competent
knows how to use
the tools of law enforcement to stop the
censorship and silence
and abuse of power okay so i know you
have to go we're gonna go behind youtube
just for two minutes with you real quick
but
i listen we know there's probably a
chance that you're gonna run in the next
election you're a popular republican
national figure maybe you will maybe you
won't will you make the promise right
now that if you run and you win
you will take executive action to make
sure that speech is free and open on
these platforms who claim to be
platforms
absolutely 100 all right i'm going to
hold you that
and if you don't you run for president
and vote for you and you win i'm going
to accuse you of attempted murder oh
it's going to be
way more in-depth and i'm going to have
receipts and there's going to be some
very
large man named lyle who works for you
so really quickly i will say if you say
murder you have to i don't know if you
saw the babylon bee article that that
had aoc lying on the ground
screaming
so it does seem to me there needs to be
a few more w's in murder if you're going
to say that this is true right really
quick
quarterback let's tell youtube to take a
hike because we're gonna do a quick
rapid fire